myanmar's former leader aung sang
she's been given a four-year prison term
for incitement the foreign secretary liz
trust has called the sentencing another
appalling attempt by myanmar's military
regime to stifle opposition and suppress
freedom and democracy
our southeast asia correspondent warren
robbins is standing by for us and it
could get even worse for siobhan
couldn't it good morning
good morning yeah unfortunately the
current situation in myanmar means
today's verdicts don't really come as a
surprise to many people and san tsuchi
as you say given four years for
incitement and breaking covert 19 rules
the ousted president also given a
four-year sentence the mayor of
napierdore two years and as a reminder
ansan tsuchi and the president were both
detained on the first of february when
the military staged a coup they claimed
they needed to stage that uh takeover of
government because they claimed there
was widespread electoral forward in the
2020 election which and samsuchi's party
won decisively thrashing the
military-backed party and since that
point there has been widespread unrest
in myanmar we've seen more than a
thousand people killed by security
forces more than ten thousand people
arrested but as you say this is really
just the start in terms of the legal
process against ansel chi so four years
already in jail a reminder she's 76
but she has several other charges
against her and in total if you add up
all the maximum sentences she could be
sentenced to more than a hundred years
we don't know at the moment if she's
going to be taken to prison or be put
under house arrest you'll remember that
from the 1980s
uh to 2010 she was actually under house
arrest and in detention for around 15
years in total so she's no stranger to
this but real outrage coming from around
the world from human rights groups and
also from governments and as you say the
british foreign secretary issuing a
statement saying the sentencing of and
sansuchi is another appalling attempt by
myanmar's military regime to stifle
opposition and suppress freedom and
democracy they are among the groups
calling for an sanctuary and immediate
release and also the release of other
political prisoners